one of the things about structure that i
found that sort of changed more than
anything for me because i didn't realize
this for the first 10 or 15 years that I
was a consultant and lecture and that is
really what we're always writing about
always and this is true for unfair i
dursn't if they never looked at a
psychologist couch and they laugh at
this when I work with them turns out
what they're writing about always I
think we're all as humans I think
there's two things or maybe it's just me
but it's very sometimes shocking to
realize that your pain and your
insecurities and fears are very very
very connected to other people in the
world I have feelings of abandonment I
have feelings of pride I have a feelings
of discouragement in other words I can
identify with him emotionally not that I
want to be him or be like him but I like
to know that he is actually not that
different from me I take issue with the
word likable because likable is the is
the death knell of filmmaking because
everybody writes characters and then the
studio says make them more likable I
found two ways to write feeling
characters in mind you well I've noticed
an interesting thing about my own
writing and this is something I'm just
sort of discovering the hiding and
deception is secrecy that's great I'm
gonna steal that can I steal though sure
I'll get yours thank you one of the
things that I think is so dramatic in a
story it's where you've got somebody
who's a little bit more on the dark side
and somebody who's more on the light
side and as the story progresses they
cross those are sort of the beats of
going through it then it's a matter of
just going through that process again
and again and again with each successive
draft but that'll that'll get you two
something if you're looking at a blank
page to begin with and you go oh yeah
that's brilliant and so that's what we
want to see in our characters so all
these things you don't know about
yourself learning them is a story that's
what makes great still
r
you